KATE HARRIS: Hi.
I'm Kate Harris, and I am a
mobile product manager that
focuses on Android at the "New
York Times." And I'm with--
FARRAH ASSIR: Hi.
I'm Farrah Assir.
I work on our Android App.
I'm a designer.
KATE HARRIS: We were actually
on Android pretty early.
Our first app debuted in 2010.
But I think we, like many
other publishers and
developers, were very rushed
to get something out there.
And we took what we knew, which
was iOS at the time, and
tried to make it work
on Android.
When Google came out with the
design principles with Android
4.0, we were very excited.
And we decided that that was the
right time to completely
rehaul what we had and embrace
the new principles and
relaunch our app.
In response, we recommitted
to Android, I'd say.
FARRAH ASSIR: Yeah.
And I think our goal was to
make it more intuitive for
Android users.
And I think that worked.
KATE HARRIS: After a lot of work
in September we were able
to relaunch our phone app.
And then quickly after, in
December, we launched our
responsive app, which took our
phone app and scaled it up so
it looked great on 7-inch
tablets and 10-inch tablets.
And so this is what our old
article looked like.
And here's our new article.
And Farrah can actually tap into
the lead photo and enter
a slideshow.
So it's a much more interactive
article
representation.
Just by looking at our list of
articles in our old app, which
Farrah is holding on the left,
and comparing it with our new
and improved list of articles
on the right, you can see
visually just how striking
the differences are.
FARRAH ASSIR: Well, it
was interesting.
Having those constraints in
place actually helped us focus
and push our ideas a little
further, kind of thinking
differently than we would have
if we just had blue skies.
So it was good to have those
suggestions or guidelines and
be able to think about
how to make it our
own app within those.
And I think they help a
lot with usability.
Android users are familiar
with these patterns.
And we were able to work
them in and still
make them our own.
Another great thing about the
redesign was the way we used
image varieties and just
optimized for the device that
the user is on.
So if you look at the tablet,
we have these big, beautiful
images that show off
our photography.
And then if you look at it on
the phone, we take into
consideration conserving data
and performance, so we load a
smaller image there.
I think how we made this app
feel like the "New York Times"
had a lot to do with
typography.
So we were able to integrate
our custom
typefaces and our colors.
And the way that we mix
typefaces together makes it
feel like the "New
York Times."
KATE HARRIS: One thing that's
great about the Google Play
store is it allows us to move
quicker with new releases.
So now we're actually launching
features on Android
first, before we roll them out
on our other platforms.
So some of the features that
have debuted first on Android
are text-to-speech, and
also comments was
rolled out on Android.
And it's something that we're
actively working on on our
other platforms, because
our users were so
engaged with the content.
So we're continually working
to improve the app.
Last week, we just
released search,
which is very exciting.
Users can search locally on
the device and also search
from the website.
We've seen incredible
growth, actually.
Since we relaunched the phone
app, our monthly unique users
have gone up over 200%.
And since we launched the
responsive app, expanding to
tablet, our tablet numbers
have increased by 500%